حول هذه التطورات معنا الان من بيروت
العميد الياس حنا الخبير العسكري
والاستراتيجي قراءه طبعا عسكريه
واستراتيجيه العميد الياس حنا في كل هذه
التطورات ودعنا نبدا
فيما يتعلق باستهداف المسيرات للمقاطعه
ازدهار نحن في تكتيك جديد مرحله جديده
ديناميكيه جديده
اصبحت قديمه جديده واصبحت تقريبا هي
السياسه المعتمده يعني لا يخلونا يوم ولا
نرى مسيرات تضرب العمق الروسي خاصه
العاصمه خاصه ضواحي العاصمه وهذا الامر
بالمعنى العسكري قد لا يعني انها ستغير
مجرى الحرب الاساسي وهذا الامر يعود او
يمكن الاستنتاج ان صناعه مسيلات اصبحت
مهمه في اوكرانيا ان المخزون الاستراتيجي
لهذه المسيرات هو متوفر من هنا كل يوم
هناك ضربه ولكن ايضا قد يعكس بطريقه غير
مباشره
التعثر الكبير الذي يحصل على الجبهه 900
كم تقريبا تم استرداد حتى الان ما يقارب
250 كيلومتر مربع من اصل 100 وعشرين الف
كيلو متر مربع من كوبيانسكو وحتى مد
الذي تحدثه هذه المسيرات
داخل
يعني الملف الروسي داخل العمق الروسي على
وجه الخصوص
الارباك الوحيد هو اظهار الامن الداخلي
الروسي على انه امن
هشق خلق
جدل بين القاده والسعي فعلا تعديل
الدفاعات الجويه الدفاعات الجويه حول
موسكو ازدهار تعود لمرحله ما قبل الحرب
البارده
وللعام 93 هناك دائرتان للدفاع عن
اوكرانيا عن موسكو ولكن كلها ضد صواريخ
النوويه ضد الصواريخ قريه متوسطه المدى
ولكن ولا صاروخ منها ولا منظومه منها
تستهدف المسيرات او لم تؤخذ بعين الاعتبار
هذه المسيرات لماذا لانه هذه المنظومه
القديمه كانت مهيئه كي لا تعطي الانذار في
حاله طيران بسيط
رف من الطيور او ما شابه اليوم هذا الامر
يضع اعباء كبيره وقلق في داخل الروسي ولكن
لن يكون نقطه في المعركه الكبرى ابقى معنا
العميد الياس حنا سنعود اليك لمزيد من
التحليل والقراءه العسكريه